And although the circumstances of our lives may seem very distant,...
...with me standing here as the First Lady of the United States of America, and you,...
...just getting through school.
I want you to know that we have very much in common.
For nothing in my life's path...
...would have predicted that I'd be standing here...
...as the first African-American First Lady of the United States of America.
There was nothing in my story that would land me here.
I wasn't raised with wealth or resources,...
...or any social standing to speak of.
I was raised on the south side of Chicago.
That's the real part of Chicago.
And I was the product of a working-class community.
My father was a city worker all of his life,...
...and my mother was a stay-at-home mom,...
...and she stayed at home to take care of me and my older brother.